(クラッカー発射の舞)
僕です！！！　はい！！！　僕です！！！
ﾋﾟｴｴｴｴｪｪｪｪwww
ﾌﾟﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙﾙwww
むっｗぷぷｗ
やぁばぁいぜぇぇ？
YouTube始めたのが
確か19歳だったかな？
それからもうすぐもう5年経とうとしてますよ！！
びっくり、マジで
はい、というわけで只今ですね
はい只今…
あと8分で誕生日でございます
えーとですね、えー、、
1人ですけども、誕生日前から本当にたくさんの方から
「おめでとうございます」というリプライを頂いて
僕はほんとに幸せだと思っております
ほんとに、ありがとうございます！！
(ｶﾞﾗｶﾞﾗｯ)
来年にはもう20代後半でございますよ
いやー、ほんとねまさか僕の人生がこんな事になるとは
思っていなかったので
今後の事は全く分かんないんですけども
皆様のおかげでとても楽しく、えー、
人生を過ごさせていただいております
やべ、こんな話をしてる間に
あと7分だ、あと7分
ひとまずあれだな…
あの、こーんかいの動画は何をするかといいますと
僕、あの、誕生日の予定 何も入れてません
全くゼロです！
牛丼 大です！！
おいしそうです！！！
今年はもうほんとにね、あの、事前にも何も聞いてない
もう誰が来るとかも何も聞いてないんですけども
誰かしら僕の家に来てくれるでしょ、
リアルな友達が
ほんと僕ですね、あの、ネット番長なんで
ほんとネットだけなんですよ僕の住処ってのは
そう思ってた、去年までは
でも今年はね、まあ、遊戯王とかも通して
リアルな友達がたくさん増えたなって
僕自身は思っているので
まあ僕の誕生日がどんなのかっていうのを
ちょっとね皆さんと共有しましょう
おおっと気づけば残り5分だ
ああ～やばいあと3分で、あと3分で誕生日だやばいやばい
LINE来てねーかな
誰も来てねーや
ｳﾜｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱ
あと2分、あと2分
「24歳おめでとうございます」
本当にありがとうございます
すごいよほんとにありがとう、
猫に囲まれてる
あと2分、あと2分
「あと1分ー(勝手にカウントダウン)」
あと1分
うわ、もうほんとねえ～…
ありがとうとしか言いようがないです
お時間を許す限りなるべく見ております
ほんとにTwitterで絡んでくださる皆さま、
いつも動画を見てくださる皆さま
ありがとうございまs((ｼﾞﾘﾘﾘﾘﾘ
ｳﾜｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱ
(ﾊﾞﾝｯ)
誕生日だあｱｱｱｱｧｧｧ
ﾄﾞﾜｱｱｱｱｵｵｵｫｫｫ
あ、食べよ
乾杯
Twitterが、どうなってるか…
(LINEの着信音)
LINEだ
＜おめでとうございまーす！
うわ、うわああああ
うわあ、うわあああぁぁぁ
後輩)おめでとうございまーす！！
(電話に向かって)あ、ありがとうございます
わ、びっくりした、ありがとう
ロバート)俺一発目すか？
は)いや、遅かった、同時タイミングくらい
ロ)同時かー
後)おめでとうございます(拍手)
は)ありがとうございます、ありがとうございます
えーすごい、マジか君たち！
あ、ありあとやす
ああ～ありがとありがと
ロバート君ありがとう！
ロ)ありがとうございます
は)また飲みに行こ？うん、…
わあああ もうちょっ、
ああ・・・
(ｸﾗｯｶｰ  ﾊﾟｧﾝ)
時間s(ﾊﾟｧﾝ) 時間(ﾊﾟﾊﾟｧﾝ) 時間差だ
ほんとマジ、1人で牛丼食いながらずっとTwitter見てたわ
(後輩爆笑)
えーありがとうございますほんとにわざわざ
(後輩拍手)
ありあとやす
後)抱負を、抱負をお願いします
抱負！？
24歳かー…
それは違うか！
は)徹夜で遊戯王やろう！！
後)ﾜｰｲﾜｰｲ
あ、そや、Twitter Twitter
皆さんほんとは、もういつもありがとうございます(?)
うわーすごい、ありがとうございます
後)それは、面白い
すーげえ
は)中国からのお祝いだ
後)やば、やばやばやばやばい
後)え、これ1人で(動画)やってたんすかこれ？
は)1人でやってた、1人でずっとこうやって
は)クラッカー鳴らして、50個、こうやって
後)(爆笑)
えやばいやばい、マジでマジで？
オイラリア充じゃないか
え、じゃあ開けますね((ｼﾞﾘﾘﾘﾘﾘﾘ
ﾜｱｧｯ(ﾊﾞﾝｯ)
皆さんからのリプが…すごい…
「いーいー」とかダメ…
すごい、開けますね
え、何なに？
は)え、開けますよ？
後)どうぞどうぞ
ﾌｯｯww
あー、なるほどね！
後)前探しに行って、なかったじゃないですか
は)あ、そっか！
いや、マジありがとう
後)これ開けてみてください
は)じゃあ開けるね
後)はい
こう、今日家で一人でいようかカラオケ一人で行こうか
は)ガチで、悩んでたさっきも
後)行きましょうよカラオケ
は)カラオケあり？
後)カラオケ行きましょう
は)カラオケあり
ええっ何これ！？
自分で作ったの？
後)作ってきました
は)嘘じゃん！
後)着てみてください
は)マジー？
後)ちょっと、見てください
ハッハッハッハ！！
「まぁ、ええんちゃう？」頂きました
後)ヤバいヤバいもう汚れた
は)えぇっえっ！？えっ？嘘！？
後)牛丼w牛丼がww　ああーw
えっ牛丼(の汚れ)って落ちるよね？落ちるよね？
落ちるよね(確信)
後)いーいーw　いーいーw
は)ダメダメ、ちょっtttちょっとちょっと
は)えっ！！
後)こういうの作れるんだ
は)ヤバいヤバい
「寝やすそうだったのでクモの巣作ってみた」か…
懐かしいねえ
後)Happy Birthday Dear はじめさーん♪
後)おめでとうます
後)(拍手)
は)ありがとうございます
うわあかわいい
wwww　後ろ二人もう完全にww
は)おわっ、なんと！
後)なんと？？
24LINE来ました(拍手)
後)ちょうど24ですね
は)あっちょうど24じゃん！
ほらちゃんと24で止まっております
はい、という訳で24歳の誕生日はネットだけではなく
リアルの方も充実しておりました
ほんとにありがとうございます皆さん
まあ24歳も、まあ怪我なく
健康に過ごせれてればいいなと思っております！
皆さん、今後ともよろしくおねしゃーす！
(ED後のオマケもお見逃しなく)
後)行きます？
は)カラオケ行くぞおおおおお！
後)おおおおおおお！！